[Music]
foreign
you know what I knew you were gonna do
that and I'm glad I'm glad this happened
because
I just was in the bathroom going oh
let's talk about
like the pronunciation of his name
because the way Bill Burr says the way
of people from Boston say it comes out
as verzy yeah and I'm like but then I
think it was shelter some was like it
was verzy like v-e-r it's weird I I do
all the shows I do and even when I've
been going on Peter Schrager on the NFL
Network I've been going on good morning
football and he knows my name is Versi
and he just insists on saying what's his
name again Peter Schrager let's call him
Peter
um
Petter yeah no it's it I know the eye
throws people but it's pronounced
version but whatever I'm not one of
those either no there's no excuse for
people not being able to say this very
simple name no
it's not it's it's Versi yep think about
jersey with the V
even though it's it's Versi
is uh you're half Sicilian half Greek
which what is it verses of Sicilian
Sicilian very Sicilian do you know what
it means by any chance because we will
find out you know what does it mean this
name is hard to pronounce it means
people keep getting it wrong that's what
it no uh can I tell you something real
quick I have ethereum working on oh
where what you're named
helps develop your personality and
ability to um communicate with people so
have you been correcting people your
whole life about your name no I don't
just here today I don't first time
can I be honest with you I think it is I
think this is the first time but here's
why can I tell you why this is why I did
it because women are dumb no because I
respect you and your show and I'm so
excited to be here and since I'm here I
want it to just be I would rather be
right out of the gate than wrong out of
the gate is that look by the way you're
a man in comedy you're right by default
no don't put that on me I'm wrong at it
I'm a dumb crackhead whore out of the
gate uh so here's the good news is
people are gonna go why is Paul bullying
that that mentally ill girl who is also
wildly dyslexic the only thing all of my
dyslexia and stuff doesn't apply to is
this name so this is the only name I
have no excuses not to pronounce right
so that's I totally obviously I don't
care and uh it's all good because I was
talking last night too um this guy I'm
dating he's like a fucking giant fan of
yours and uh and he was like it's verzy
and I was like I know but Bill Burr says
verzi but Bill's always so Stark raving
angry that maybe it just comes out
yeah Bill Bill actually does it calls me
Paul rarely he says version a lot but no
it's it's
not many people call me veersy well no
because it's it's a slur it's an insult
it's a disrespectful I don't I wouldn't
take it as disrespect I would just take
it I meant it so now you're bullying I'm
trying to disrespect you it's very hard
our business our listeners they're so in
in everything we do in business they're
so sick aren't they they'll be like why
would he they're you're gonna get this
you're gonna get this on why would he
like correct her at the beginning like
such a and I'm it's I've learned people
that listen to my podcast
um
they literally sent emails comments
saying that my computer screen is too
dirty for that I mean they're on your
side what's in the background you know
those people what do you know like
they'll be like why are there do you
have like a laundry bin and it's like
it's like I'm giving content it's free
it's free can you just yeah but this is
for you but also imagine how big of a
fan someone is that they're gonna go out
of your way so I'm drawing on my
eyebrows
um that they're gonna go out of their
way to ask about the maybe you know why
by the way what do how much do we owe
them I don't know because I think it
would actually be fun to do a podcast
episode of everyone's questions that are
ridiculous and just answer them all
what's in your background that's a
laundry bin we good
yeah Paul why did you do this I you know
like just answer them it's the worst I
don't know I think that when someone is
I don't know I think I'm a little bit um
uh what's the word hopeful when it comes
to podcast fans because I think we are
all sort of podcasting because we we
like doing it guys I think unclear we
like doing it but we also know we have
to this is a big part of our job now
right it used to be you guys see us once
a year either in your hometown or
whatever at a show and then you'll see a
special once every two years a year
you'll see now you listen to us talk for
truly three or four hours a week how can
we possibly complain about someone who
wants to hear from us that much my own
family has never heard of me talk for
that long that is true yeah that's true
and and somebody said so I think it was
was it Tiffany haddish somebody said
when your hater takes time
I had somebody write me a letter of hate
recently oh really yeah hey I mean it
went it got personal it was and then I
was just like if this dude's doing this
yeah I did something where he's kind of
a fan no 100 you got to be a fan and
then I also think that when people
really believe in you they have even
higher standards of how you should like
so some it's like a huge fan of yours
I'm like dude this thing you said didn't
make sense and you're like fuck you I
can say what I want they're like no but
I'm just trying to help you because I
want you to be the biggest comic on the
planet that's yeah you got a lot of ways
I think sometimes when I don't look at
negative comments as people shitting I
think I look at it as constructive
criticism that sometimes like Gets Lost
in Translation or it's a lot of times
it's people trying to be funny yeah you
know what I mean and it just doesn't
Translate
yeah I just don't like when people get
personal like don't get personal but I
feel like we get so personal too that
I'm not blaming this isn't I'm just
saying like I just always try to go like
what's my part in this because I'll be
like and anyway when I had butt sex in
the back of a Taurus with a guy named
Glenn Marcus in 1992 and then they're
like what was up with that Taurus you
know don't get personal I don't oh cause
you're saying you gave I got it yeah
yeah I I feel like we kind of
chronically not overshare we're con you
know but then when someone comes up to
us in an airport and I was like Hey anal
sex in in the Taurus you're like excuse
me how dare you I don't think I could
ever go dare you bro how do you bring up
the thing that I bring up every podcast
episode this is rude yeah please get
away from me yeah how dare you bring a
butt sex that I brought up in a tourist
you know what I'm saying it's just like
sometimes people hold mirrors up and
we're like put the mirror down yeah how
dare you isn't it weird that like I
never thought I would drop out of
college to be like a radio host like we
have to like we have to do right like I
dropped out of college to do stand-up my
dream my dream was Eddie Murphy okay
that was it that was it I was saw Eddie
on I saw raw my dad took me when I was
10 years old and you know that because
of raw
I always have like red leather somewhere
near me that's well no that's delete uh
Delirious was red and raw was the black
and blue uh
oh yeah and and oh then Delirious well
yeah whatever the because I remember
seeing him in the red leather yeah just
like four or five years ago I mean like
why aren't we all
we are why are we wearing hoodies for
these people that are getting
babysitters and driving to see us at
these fucking nightmare comedy clubs
where they're eating frozen yeah fish
sticks or whatever the fuck they're
being served and they are getting beer
poured on them by the fucking yeah
whatever uh and we're showing up in
fucking hoodie under armor hoodies why
can't we just dress why can't we
entertain a little bit a little Pizzazz
without killing anyone yeah little flash
here yeah yeah that's the thing I'm a
little I'm starting to get I'm starting
to get in touch with my inner like the
real inner Guido there's a little Guido
in there but here's the thing yeah but
the guido gets watered down because of
the Greek because you just stood in the
rain for uh 45 minutes outside my house
and I didn't know you're standing there
I was like listen I like Whitney but if
these Jordans get wet for another five
minutes I'm not doing the show and I'm
getting back and they really sucks it's
pouring rain in L.A dude and I look
outside and I'm just walking by and you
know when you can tell someone's been
standing there a while like I knew
you were like you could just look at my
face and be like that's like three and a
half minutes like I Knew by your
shoulders and just by your like the way
you were kind of like trying to figure
out how to get less wet and I could tell
I could tell he was like looking through
a chain of a text to get my number yes I
was like yeah I was I was like no this
is fine this is fine then another minute
went by and I was like I think I hear
footsteps and then I was like if it's
not footsteps I might leave I might and
it was the one part where the gutter was
clogged so it was like just a hoe it was
one hose right next up is the most
disrespectful I was just like why did I
wear these Jordans and then I was like
hey Paul verzie come on in it was fine
it was fun
um but yeah dude so inner Guido walk me
through this and and really quick the
word Guido I think like there's like a
new generation of people that maybe call
people might not even know what it means
yes so there's different levels I was
actually just talking about this on uh
with another comic about this so there
are different levels of Guido like
that's a great question and somebody
asked me that no it's how you it's how
you say it if you're like ah this
fucking if you do it like that then it's
like but if it's like
right okay right you know but I don't go
like I'm not a pinky ring guy I'm not
but I gotta have listen I gotta have one
this is part of me this is part of me oh
okay oh no this is part of one okay yeah
a bishop has to be as it's like this is
part of Who I Am Shane can I see a
question about the chain yeah what
decides the length of the chain you
can't go too low but hot but I don't
also don't need a I can't have a hugger
It's gotta be right I'm actually my wife
handed this to me in between shows of my
first special and I haven't taken it off
since in 2018 when I did my Comedy
Central special she gave me this and
this is part of you know but I'm a one
chain but let me ask you something but
this I think that men's jewelry is
important yeah because man you guys I'm
I'm 2023 defending men
um hot tank so guys don't get to have
jewelry they don't get to have hairs to
everything that
um is sort of in the socially
constructed that is considered beautiful
with women we can change it
right so if we don't have uh uh thick
hair we can add someone uh uh I stand
with Ukraine but my hair is Russian we
can add someone else's I thought you
were just gonna pull half your hair out
can you imagine if you were just like
yeah we could just do this no you're
just holding a fuck
I would have been like damn let's just
Scout myself so I can add someone else's
hair to my head and not wash it for days
and like I can do this and it's fine
right if you did this people would call
the um police yeah and you your children
will be taken from you if you if you
glued someone else's hair to your head
yeah right yeah so if you have like a
zit that you know you're about to shoot
another special you have a zit like you
just have a zit and you're special right
right right but I can put like caulk and
grout on it and everyone knows I've got
caulking like makeup on it and they see
it and they're like that's fine yeah
like we can fix most of the Cosmetic
things whereas like if we're too short
we can wear heels
yes you know what I mean like we could
just change we can wear
um what's it called uh harnesses under
our under we can wear harnesses yeah to
change the shape of our bodies women can
morph into something they're not
completely 100 and by the way are lauded
for it right you know what I mean right
where'd you get that hair that is stuck
to your head that someone else's you
know what I mean yeah yeah but guys like
if you so much as do haircut any of it
yeah if you draw in a little bit I just
draw it in an eyebrow on camera like a
psycho yeah and no one will care yeah no
that was I saw that that was wild if you
do this it's like yeah if I just started
like you'll get your kids taken from you
yeah
I just start putting chunks of beard on
like they would be like you just can't
so guys they can't wear they can't do
their nails they can't uh uh wear
jewelry
sneakers and maybe cotton car belts and
hats
yeah kind of it yeah watches is a big
one but I'm not I'm not like crazy but
here's the thing I'm into white leather
in the car so I just got a Lexus right
and it was like a couple in the country
that had the colors I needed because I
said I need dark outside the car dark
outside dark outside white leather white
leather or as close to white leather as
you can and it just pops and it's sick
the only thing I would say is let's make
sure your wife gets those super
absorbent tampons
well no she's not allowed in the car but
you know I mean that's a that's a given
you know neither are the kids it's my
car but what I'm saying is I mean when
you think I'm getting a car white let
anybody in my car
um I bring baby wipes in the car and I
wipe down I mean it's crazy so no as you
look it's I'm if I have this Theory
like whenever um a guy I'm dating is
like like I need help with something
like like can you put a Band-Aid on that
my finger can you help me with like
tweezers I just I'm about to go to that
thing and then when they're like I just
I don't know what I'm supposed to be
doing I'm like
um how about just look look at me treat
me half as well as you treat your car
yeah and that's like a shortcut so just
pretend I'm your car
that's it and then they're like oh I got
it here's the baby wipes uh here you
need I got like that they hug you they
start cleaning stuff they know it
they hug you they're like oh in that
case they give you a kiss
and that it all makes sense because
boats and cars are she
not interesting that is interesting she
no one ever and you're no one's you're
not driving around in your white Lexus
being like there he is
there's my dude right now no you're like
there is my baby there she is that's my
little baby yeah yeah that's my baby
that's really funny like it's weird it's
it's interesting that boats are she and
cars are she and I have a theory with
part of the reason a lot of men hate
women so much is that if you name your
or think of your car your boat as a she
You're Gonna Hate any she's because
boats and cars break down and they're
fucking they don't work a lot and
they're expensive stop associating us
with your expensive fucking money pit
purchase do you think men hate women no
so Paul you know how you just say
something you know how you say an
exaggeration for Comic effect yeah yeah
no no check out an internal admissions
he does it for 60 minutes straight and
it's great at it but if I do it no no I
knew it I bet uh no I get it but I was
just like you know you made me think of
when you did the hugging thing
I was like I hugged my wife the other
day right in front of my daughter
and listen it's a pretty big thing oh
it's a big thing it's a big thing okay
one of the best quotes I ever heard
you're gonna love this John Wooden okay
love him John Wood you know coach UC
UCLA yes that's right 11 championships
whatever uh inches make champions
and it was about dicks yes he's got two
of my favorites okay he's got
um
[Laughter]
I think that's his number one that's on
the Hall of Fame working with therapist
can help you get closer to the best
version of you if you're thinking of
giving a therapy a try better help is a
great option it's convenient flexible
affordable entirely online
here's the other thing about therapy you
don't have to do do it forever like I
think a lot of people are like I don't
want to go to therapy and you're like
just got like one just go to one session
if it works go to another one if it
works go to another one you know what I
mean and then if you want to switch
counselors you can
10 years ago the sentence I just said
that would have been a disrespectful
thing to say to someone or uh elitist
because it would be like oh just switch
therapists 10 years ago switching
therapists took like eight months
you're like finding new one someone had
to like tell you where to go you know
like drives eight miles and get the
insurance and deal with there's it would
have a nightmare now you could just
click click clack click the little
computer guy
new therapist
blink of an eye all you do is fill out a
brief questionnaire to get matched with
a licensed therapist and switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge what if you want to live a more
empowered life therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com Whitney today and
get 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash Whitney failure to
prepare is preparing to fail is
preparing to fail
okay okay but he was also a white guy
and they don't fit they didn't fail
around that time so if okay so that's
great if you're like great advice for
the Glam mosque and like uh but I think
for some people it's like preparing to
fit
that but also like have like a little
bit of a plan B not that you're gonna
fail but like
like what if you went out last night you
couldn't yeah like just in case after
the wedding he like hits you on the
wedding night like like just have your
credit in order have a you know what I
mean like have you then have a like
if he like hits you on your wedding
night after a couple Jack Daniels and
seeing the bill uh for the you know
shrimp
you know just Bob and weave it's on have
a play you know I mean bitch that's four
double my pages I said two but it was an
open bar I thought it was an open bar
you didn't tell me to stop being an open
bar at 11. it was three the band they
had extra shrimp okay but why but I
didn't why didn't you tell the band to
stop playing if it's if it it was
overtime we went to overtime on the
fucking band oh that's great I could
have just put fucking Journey on my iPod
and I have this fucking guy
playing it's a you're a brick house like
why is this how it's going to be
famous but my favorite one is
um the best thing a a man or a father
can do for his children is love their
mother
and I've seen that and because like
when you fight sometimes with your
spouse and your kids feel it you could
feel that they don't like it but when
it's the opposite like I hug my wife in
the kitchen and I just saw my my kids
like lift up and you're like oh shit
that's like a heavy thing because
they're like yeah sometimes they'll get
a little uncomfortable if they hear an
argue me and my wife won't scream at you
but like even if it's just why'd you
take my car you know or something like
that guys your question yeah and this
camera will get it so I'm uh I do feel
like every now and then I'm tiptoeing by
accident into like future sexual
predator Behavior
like by accident like I shoot my pockets
at my house and I and I'm like hey come
check out my bedroom like if I was a
scumbag in 10 years everyone would be
like
oh yeah dude
remember when she was just like Whitney
was not some shit it was like it it just
seemed at the time like spoofy lady with
her like she did bring me into her
bedroom and like show me deer or
whatever the fuck we just did it was
kind of a romantic moment but can I just
get I just would like a little tutorial
I'm 40 years old and I'm not sure how to
hug
anyone we didn't have a lot of hugging
growing up in my home there are my dad
and I never physically touched each
other really at all until uh my
graduation from I believe it was College
there's a photo of him standing next to
me and like hugging me from the side and
it's like so awkward because we just
didn't he would like write me cards
later like he just couldn't really like
he had a son and then two daughters and
we would like he would like throw the
basketball at me really hard like that
was how we
like basket we were like you know uh
playing basketball
uh he would we would drive around like
we would drive around um
like do you see at the time of where we
were Virginia and he would point out
like the way that we had father daughter
Thomas he would point out businesses and
explain to me why they were scams and
like money laundering schemes you know
okay so he'd be like oh good the cell
phone store where they fixed your cell
phone well and then they they make sure
it's broken uh when they fix it so
they'll have to come back you know like
he'll just explain the whole fucking
thing Circuit City okay so here's the
fucking thing about Sir for him they're
all liars thieves and worms like you do
this whole thing with me going like this
is why you never whatever and then
Subway the bread that's not Brad like he
knew that shit like 20 years ago he was
on Subway bread which now we know is
like yoga mats yeah the one thing I
didn't learn is so you're hugging your
wife so that's there's a certain kind of
hug that is like you don't have to do it
if you don't want what no I mean I could
give a normal hug I mean I'm not good
okay so but don't hug me hug okay how
did you hug your wife in front of your
kids no I just you just I just came over
and just just like well that's like okay
because that's your kids were like oh
they've never met I mean that feels a
little I like from a guy a big like bear
hug but that might look aggressive to a
kid
yeah like I I just should it was more of
just like I'm hugging Mommy because I
love and appreciate her I love and
appreciate my wife so much and my wife
is such a strong woman and I want you
guys to know how strong and awesome your
mom is so I'm just gonna be on the
bottom arm wise no it's I think it's
it's doesn't have to I think if you're
dating someone you as a girl you can go
up but to go on up on someone you're not
dating is like wait like if I saw you
and your wife at The Comedy Store yeah
and I get to meet her for the first time
if I saw you
and we hugged I wouldn't be like I
wouldn't go up
right yeah I wouldn't go down okay you
go down yeah well I'd probably go like I
just feel does height matter
height has to matter here well because
that's the other thing here's why my
wife's five one she's very smart she
wouldn't see anything anyway she's smart
she's smaller I love that good for her
so like no matter where I go I'm just
taking her like it's so it looks uh uh
it's like an enveloping her right so my
kid to my kids it doesn't matter how it
is it's just like oh Daddy's you know
you know what I think is kind of cool is
like doing a lot of sort of like you
know whatever research I've been able to
do to understand like what uh parental
dynamics that we saw the Optics we saw
growing up what helps because all
children always know everything like the
worst thing we can do they say is lie to
children like if you're arguing or if
you lose your temper yeah the worst
thing you can do is go guys
um mommy and daddy were working on a
scene
because we like to we're actors and we
like to sometimes uh do acting scenes oh
yeah my kids don't play that you can't
do that they just know you're lying to
that they just know and then when you
lie about it they start they can't
handle the uh that idea that their
parents are dishonest or would lie to
them so they just blame themselves yeah
and they go oh I must be crazy I'm gonna
doubt myself I'm gonna doubt my own
reality yep the best thing you do is go
like what the fuck was that and then be
like kids
Daddy I just I'm sorry I just lost my
temper or yes that's actually doing that
call them say Hey listen this is what
happened my daughter has that was my
billboard impression that was that was
I'm sorry
ah daddy lost his temper
and it will happen again it's what
happened no um my daughter senses
everything Whitney it's so crazy to the
point where she called me in two years
ago before now myself
oh yes no like her office
she she called me in a room she said sit
down how about this into your room huh
it's your room into into my room into
your room because she would she likes to
watch her phone by the charger next to
our bed because our dog lays there right
so she goes dad come in here and I was
going back and forth and she says I need
to talk to you and I need you to be
honest with me and I said well okay and
she says you got to tell me what's to do
what the deal with Santa Clauses right
and I said let's go and I said what she
goes okay she goes I've been hearing
things
and I've been seeing some things and I
need you to tell me I swear to God she
goes you know is this guy real because
look if I'm gonna sit on this guy's lap
at the mall I gotta know yeah because
this says it doesn't add up to me to
wait in line to sit on this guy's lap is
a little fishy yeah and she starts going
like he can't get all the houses like
what's something's wrong
there's no way he can get all the houses
he can't get in the world he can't get
so she goes because he's uh he's obese
and and the thing would fall the the
sleigh can't I mean he'll be exhausted
after like Rhode Island but then you
have to go but there's Mrs Claus who's
handling Mo Mrs claw behind every great
man yeah Mrs Claus is handling shit but
she's like older than him
shockingly Mrs Claus looks like 97 and
Santa always looks like 60s yeah Santa
always looks like 14 years younger
doesn't he which means like she's aged
prematurely from the stress of trying to
churn out
the like Nutcracker well she's probably
getting on him like you you slacked last
year you're getting lazy yeah yeah for
sure you know we got to watch the
cookies because it's fucking you up it's
a little too much you know yeah and also
dude
um you're just some guy and you think
you're Santa so stop and Santa can't
become diabetic yeah you can't can't so
and you gotta stop going into people's
homes in the middle of the night it's
weird yeah it's it's 20 23 like what
what are we doing here no so so my
daughter goes yeah my daughter goes uh
she goes I go yeah you know listen and
this is how I try to get around it I go
the spirit of Christmas is always real
like I tried doing that the spirit of
Christmas it's good and she goes all
right well I'm going to tell you
something she goes if I find out he's
not real she goes I'm gonna be pissed
and I just walked out of the room seems
like you already are sweet pea and I
said to my wife I go dude she knows I go
she knows and she's at the time uh seven
eight she's at the time she's around
eight eight and a half years old uh she
just did and where are we and then
you're like hey okay honey what's that
tooth fairy we got there's a couple
things Easter Bunny
yeah that those were easier though once
you find out the big man's not real the
other ones but also I'm curious because
I I I it's full disclosure my last
special I had jokes kind of about
um surveillance stuff and privacy and
why it's like fine and who gives a shit
and why are we like the ship sailed on
it but I do I did try to make an
argument and just kind of gave up on it
that um surveillance is actually a good
thing because really this is listening
this is like when we know we're being
watched we do behave better
right yeah generally if you know there's
cameras watching or someone listening or
we're hearing a podcast like it does
change the way you behave right so I
think that a lot of what's the purpose
that Santa served is like think about
whenever Santa was invented like 400
years ago or whatever uh I do want to
talk about the Scandinavian can you find
the Santa the racist Santa party that
they have and I think it's Sweden or
Denmark where they do like blackface
Santa like a parade in the street still
to this day in Holland he's called Black
Pete because he goes up and down
chimneys so that's why he's all black oh
right that's why yeah okay okay but
whatever anyway so Santa think about
being a parent 400 years ago how the
fuck are you gonna control your kid
they're just like throwing shit they're
running away they're just like moving in
with Nate they're just you can't find
them they're outside yeah and then
someone had to just be like uh someone's
watching you
and if you don't behave a certain way
you're not getting presents yeah you
know so are you naughty or nice we're
making a list all year right and then
right it's it and then kids all of a
sudden are like sorry how else would you
have controlled children that's actually
a really good point you gotta yeah you
gotta threaten with like you're being
watched all year all year by
surveillance that's actually someone
that's not me
right and he's he's I don't have any
there's an eye in the sky watching you
always he's I don't decide what he does
he's this guy we can't control it's
actually a cruel thing to tell a kid but
it I'm sure they've gotten lying yeah
100 years ago if you if you couldn't
whip them anymore or whatever they did
or they did there was no room in the
factories for them to work in
that's crazy this is Black Pete my thing
is that took these people
I don't know this was probably organized
what two or three months this hang of
these people yeah and it looks really
but they that's it you have to do the
shoe polish was like yeah like you saw
like that took
two and a half hours to apply yeah that
like that's how bad you want to be in
blackface at what point are you like
halfway done going maybe this is a bad
fucking idea or like like
maybe I just stay in my home and be
racist and just do it here let's just do
it and have like our own racist party at
home instead of like going through this
yeah that's like and then but look at
this guy I can't tell if he's
back you don't have to go in the black
face it doesn't seem like you can go
he's laughing he's well he's kind of
just like hey guys we can do this parade
without the uh shoe polish on our faces
key to blackface is how well it's
applied because then you know how often
they've applied it in the past oh so if
these were just like you're like that
black face kind of sloppy you know what
uh uh uh it's not about mistakes it's
about patterns so you did it once you
fuck up don't do it this is they've done
this yearly people should test Justin
Trudeau because he said he only did it
once let's see how that application came
on I think dude he had help
okay that's even double that's even
double wrote someone else if somebody
else is into it and they're not in there
and they're they're not saying hey this
might be a bad idea sabotage well so
someone was like I'll apply your black
face Justin Trudeau my pleasure yeah I
didn't vote for you he had it on his
hands
Justin Trudeau
could you look up Justin and it wasn't
just his face his hands were black like
he was sparing no expense he takes his
underwear off
just everywhere like he took it too far
like buddy you're this you're just this
this took a full day so images
so look at his hands right here far
right far right yep look at his hand oh
yeah his hands are in blackface Black
Hand
black face is one thing black hand off
the wrist but with the wrist you cut how
by the way look at the chest where did
it stop
if at all
and how about this let me do you one
better
this is something you could do blackface
with right he put it on he's holding
some white woman by the neck uh or I
don't know and and look that should go
off on her skin right
technically it should not it's not he
used a setting spray you guys
in makeup you have something called a
setting spray of course I don't have it
with me right now but it's a spray that
makes it
stuck in okay and not rub off it's like
a top coat yeah this motherfucker like
had a top coat like practice to make
sure it didn't uh you know what I mean
look at his you could tell that's not
the first you could tell dude it's up to
the white of his eye like it's he got
conjunctivitis from this and it was
worth every it was worth it he got pink
eye it looks better than some real black
people
like it actually is like I've seen I
have black friends that it's not that
perfect it's just like yeah I'm gonna
[Laughter]
Sunday's is air dry dog food made from a
short list of human grade ingredients
Sundays was co-founded by Dr Tori a
practicing veterinarian Sundays contains
90 Meat 10 vegetables and zero percent
synthetic nutrients we love it besides
USDA beef and all natural chicken you'll
find digestive AIDS like pumpkin and
ginger plus disease fighting
antioxidants unlike any other fresh dog
food Sundaes is zero prep zero mess and
zero stress even for me I can make
stress out of anything I still can't
find flaw in it Sundays is a shelf
stable which makes it easy to feed your
pup top quality food every order ships
right to your door so you'll never worry
about running out of dog food again
genius Sundays is Affordable it costs 40
less than other Healthy dog food brands
because Sundays doesn't waste money
shipping Frozen packages thanks Sundays
instead of doing that they spend money
on what actually matters like sourcing
the best all-natural ingredients for
your pup but this one has been such a
game changer for me because most dog
foods they come in these like giant bags
they're like 85 pounds and you'll like
rip your rotator cuff just trying to
like put it in a trash can to then feed
your dog with like a big scooper and
then you got food in your garage or
wherever and then rats come and ants
come and then Sundays came in hot
changed my life solved problems I didn't
even know I had we worked out a special
deal for our dog loving listeners get 35
off your first order of Sundays go to
Sundays for dogs.com
Whitney or use code Whitney at checkout
that's Sundays
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s.com forward
slash Whitney upgrade your pup to
Sundays and feel good about the food you
feed your dog
you and raising kids and then I have all
these um questions I want to ask you uh
and then I do want to talk about
nocturnal emissions and admissions
um uh Netflix is why does it say Netflix
is a joke special do they say that now
instead of just Netflix special day
because you filmed it because at the
festival no no they they what it was was
we didn't know if it was going there so
like me and I think there was a few like
uh Chrissy D Santino there's a few that
are it's now like Netflix is a joke yeah
yeah yeah you shoot it and then they
take it or something like that yeah yeah
yeah
Tim Dylan uh so it's just something
though I I don't uh because I paid for
mine and licensed it but I don't know if
mine said I'm sure it does on the poster
oh okay yeah yeah so the nice thing was
with nocturnal admissions is when we
talked to them they were like hey man we
love Paul but it's a lot lot of
competition and we don't know and then
when they saw it they were like this
belongs here and that's what that's what
we all felt really good about because
the work was done so
um yeah shout out to those guys I really
it did so well thank God you know
because when once it's out then it's out
of our control and that's what's kind of
scary like that I do I will say my wife
is like oh you suck like you changed the
last
24 hours before it comes out because I'm
just like all right here we go you know
here we go and she's like you seem tense
it's like being in the roller coaster is
about to start like you know when you're
at the top of the roller coaster it's
like it's like you're you're locked in
and you're like like the anticipation
you're like that could die or this could
change my life in a good way yeah the
the and the reviews within the first 48
hours are like pretty much what's gonna
stay
reviews but hold on can I ask you a
question yeah reviews let me just you
guys know me and my uh stance on reviews
uh I'll do my quote real quick
um not for this is your John Wooden this
is not a John Wooden quote this is an
Oscar Wilde quote which I don't for a
minute believe any of his quotes were
his
um uh they were all his Mistresses
there's no way he had that many fucking
quotes
yeah but he did say or whoever said he
stole it from said um uh critics are
people that go to the battle site where
the war has been won and they shoot the
survivors
so critics that have never done comedy
right or aren't just fans of Comedy
um you're a loser
I get that you're a you're a dork and
um no one likes you
and we uh you're a talent list let's
just keep going all right let's go
you're talentless by the way you're
judgmental spineless
[Music]
they
effects no because fact list is when you
like your Reckless you're careless right
they care like they spend and then she
was punching down
um but I don't mean that and she's
problematic yeah yeah but yeah and I
agree with that I think those people how
dare you tell uh you don't get to decide
if communist democracy and you shot this
and um the people La the people laughing
yeah decide so so Comics here's the
thing about us we don't need you to
critique us because the audience does it
for us right that's uh what we do so we
say a joke if they don't laugh we change
it yeah uh we don't do a special where
everyone's unanimously thinks it's
hilarious and then you go well I know
now but we don't we think you're um
uh like have we think you are um
like sick
uh and like call your dad and like work
because he dropped the ball on you and
just like just work it start working out
it out with him right or get like
GarageBand and start building your dream
yeah yeah do your you do you think do
your thing yeah make drawings put them
on you want to be an artist be a
journalist be a become a comic come to
the fucking dark side over here the
bright side really and be like hey I
used to be a journalist that um fucking
critiqued Comics wasn't that weird yeah
for slate.com I know and then be a comic
yeah and and what's funny is we want
these people to pass Us in clubs when
we're coming up we want to get past in
clubs and it's somebody that never lived
in our shoes never stood there in a bomb
never had to go through that what's your
qualification for deciding oh you were a
waitress four years ago here
you handed out fucking nachos here and
then now you're saying Who belongs in in
the room but what about but the fans
what I'm saying too is like if a movie's
good right like when Godfather came out
the masses were like this is fucking
incredible I kind of mean the fans that
weren't in the room no you're kidding
nope no you're kidding nope no you're
fucking with me nope you've never seen
Godfather I saw a little bit of the open
because I recently tested for Francis
farcopola so I watched a little bit at
the beginning like the Party part did
you see the offer did you watch this no
but I would like to the offer which is
about the making of The Godfather I but
the documentary about the making of
Apocalypse Now I love but you know what
I'm doing and I actually have this
written down I swear to God I prepare
for these see virginity that matters so
what I'm trying to do
prove it
well because I'm sure this seems like I
didn't prepare for this at all I didn't
fucking pronounce his name right so can
I can I earn the respect guys
here so and we're thrilled to have Paul
Mooney is here uh well I had to have him
in the rain so the black face would at
least wash off so we could do a fucking
interview so I like to leave my guests
in the rain to make sure their makeup
comes off face makeup all over my rental
right now it is and then we're going to
talk about uh get back to Guido but yeah
sure I'm uh uh The Godfather I'm
obsessed with because I can't really
offer to anyone I've ever uh that I
might be with seriously in the future uh
my vaginal virginity or uh uh any holes
really so I have I think subconsciously
but not saved a couple movie going
experiences for my guy so I've I'm a
virgin in other ways I've never seen
Star Wars
wow can so the person I am with that I
decided to be with forever like
I'll watch Star Wars if you didn't see
Good Fellas I'm leaving
you saw good films I see Good Fellas
every night in the hallway of The Comedy
Store I've seen Good Fellas but I
haven't seen the movie wow so that's
another great one Good Fellas that's
with um the the the the
um uh
I mean is this serious my cousin Vinnie
is in it oh my God Joe Pesci I wasn't
ready to do a movie cinema fucking
podcast give me a minute and I'll
regroup and I'll kick your ass on
documentaries did you see as far as Gump
I did all right and I have we should you
know everyone's like oh my God God
remember that movie about the guy the
kid and the the metal leg braces and his
the love of his life had AIDS yeah she'd
like hoard around Jenny had it
and somebody said he got AIDS too which
is crazy they I don't so she to handicap
boy do the AIDS fuck up or so that would
mean they fucked if he got AIDS too well
they had a kid together
so the kid has AIDS
everybody's got AIDS to end the kid's
gonna need them to wear fucking hell why
would you have kids with someone that
had couldn't fucking figure out how to
open a box of chocolate and right I mean
life is nothing like a box of chocolate
your time frame on the movie is so
hilariously off
the box came after the legs
he was sitting on the bench if a guy
can't figure out how to how life works
by the way how good is your life that
you think it's like a box of chocolates
right how well are things going for you
it's so funny for me I'm like life is
like a box of cyanide
mixed with a bunch of electricity mixed
with a couple rapists that I sometimes
have to work for that's my life but I'm
glad yours is full of chocolate life is
like a box of pedophiles
you don't know which one you're gonna
get
life is like a box of AIDS that's the
clip life is like a box of pedophiles
you know
you're kidding
to pedophiles you don't know what island
you're sailing to you know what
no I think you do and that's why you're
going there I think you're getting on
you're rowing to that Island
specifically because there's a there's
tiny buttholes oh shit although I am
tearing up you know what I am Pro
Forrest Gump you know why why because he
called Jenny Jenna he didn't pronounce
Jenna his name right
but he loved her so Paul verzi verzie
Jen yeah he said Jenny yeah he said
Jenny so Paul Vero
I'll take that over there so why not let
me be mentally
neurodivergent you could call me
whatever he's fine thank you so much but
you know what I like really quick I just
love that white guys get to make movies
where they're just jogging and then it
gets uh Awards can you imagine if I've
made a movie where I was just like
jogging
everyone be like um
it's like in love with some guy that
Hades you on a treadmill in a gym no
yeah it's just me running on the street
and everyone's like Oscars pennies
you're like
like imagine Forrest Gump of The Woman
Whitney Cummings on 38 miles but so
the guy that I'm gonna either marry have
a kid with or whatever the fuck that's
what I was gonna say and I like I like
that because when I first started dating
Stacy she never saw Scarface and they
did a New York City theatrical release
of it and we go in and it's packed and
like as soon as he comes in and he's
like I'm Tony Montana the whole place
you rubbing crazy no wait watch and she
was just like so that is cool that you
get to sit down with somebody watch The
Godfather Good Fellas you could have
like a mafia red wine pasta weekend
because I think that a lot of times when
people meet like I just think it's so
cool that when you met Stacy and she
said she hadn't seen Scarface you were
like ah never mind she's not for me
that's a good thing I was like we're
doing this together because if she's
seen Scarface it means she's fucked
Italian after Italian after Italian and
after Italian you know what I mean
you're like oh this Angelic yeah un
unscathed baby watch it with me I'll
protect you her eyes haven't seen drug
lords yet so for me I'm like the way
that I can uh love my future dude like I
really try to not watch really important
movies to like got like dorks because I
I'm for sure gonna marry a fucking dork
and so I've I haven't seen Star Trek
Star Wars
can I just see one not the other
Star Wars I'm a Star Wars I can't I
don't watch Star Trek I watch Star Wars
okay but is that like Howard Opie and
Anthony like what is Coke Pepsi I I
don't some people think so I don't I
think Star Wars is just the best but
Star Trek feels like the Mad TV to the
Star Wars SNL I would actually agree
with that I would actually think that
that's a great analogy actually yeah not
that nothing wrong with man yeah yeah
yeah I mean okay but Star Wars is Star
Wars
don't want to burn a bridge
[Laughter]
anyway so
what what's your new one what are you
doing hey give me black face yeah hold
on
hey hey oh that reminds me yeah I'm
Eddie Murphy I don't even know what
impression I'm doing yeah
um Eddie Murphy you watched Eddie Murphy
and it changed your life raw yeah my
father
so my parents were divorced when I was
five and my brother was 10. and uh which
is how we know he's hilarious the courts
only gave my dad and there was no like
abuse there was no like G it was just
they were just bad bad mix just didn't
work can I tell you it happens so often
and you know what I call it a whoopsie
it could be when when the same with my
parents they fell in love yeah I think
they no one gets married thinking
they're going to get a divorce which is
tricky because then it's like don't plan
for failure you're gonna fail you're
gonna fall whatever that yeah yeah you
know
um but I think that happened with my
parents too I think they really were in
love they really wanted to work it out
yeah but they just didn't have the tools
yet well my dad was more of like we're
gonna get a mansion and a boat and
matching fur coats and Rolexes and my
mom because he's like I don't wanna my
mom was like I don't need all that and
they just they had different personality
so is he single no because he sounds
like my type of fucking guy not real
minks though when he's like wait a
minute he's gonna bring me home a
fucking yeah yeah you know fur with him
Alexa yeah just do like a faux fur
the Rolex is good the boat this may be
fine because if you if you dock a boat
in California you don't have to pay
taxes because you're on the boat yeah so
the smart guy is in La unfortunately
live in Marina Del Rey on boats but
every oh dude this houseboat thing have
you ever see are you dating someone
don't tell me you're dating someone have
you though been on apps at all in La a
lot of times there's like you'll see a
guy like the third one it's like him and
like a dog that's not his and then like
him and like his sister who he is
estranged from but just needed the photo
for you know yeah look like he got along
with women in his family and then the
third one would be like him on his
houseboat and then you start texting
like come hang out in my houseboat and
you're like I love that you're not
paying taxes and you're smart about
business but at the same time like I
don't know if I want to have
conversations with the guy I'm dating
like this
hearing water hit just like so where
should we go to dinner
should we you should do that as a bit
you should do that why the fuck it and
you're just like dude that's a bit dude
I'm not that's a joke that's a good bit
because you could do it even like a Sit
standing there talking
seriously fuck you
fuck you never again now what would be
funny here yeah you had this profound
thing I'm out of here shut up
yeah you had like a profound thing and
you fell like yeah dude I'm just like
I'm over but dude the movie overboard
that I've seen that's a great one the
old one there was a new one without it
that's a great one excellent so the my
dad only had like we only saw my dad on
Sundays and Wednesdays and movies was a
big thing for us yeah so my grandmother
and mother were like you can't take him
to see Eddie Murphy how do you decide
what you're allowed to see 10. well my
dad I was like 10 and they're like you
can't take him to see like a black man
succeeding at something and he took me
[Laughter]
God forbid go you know what how about
this don't watch Eddie Murphy Rock go
watch The Cosby Show again yeah yeah no
and that's it something wholesome yeah a
family show
which by the way just real quick sorry I
don't mean to talk about Cosby anymore
because the last couple of episodes of
the show I have um spoken about how
because he is touring again I am
offering to open for him on the road uh
and uh for the low price of I'll pay you
30 grand to do it I'm completely
obsessed with the fact that he's touring
again
um and I'd like to go because you know
retard uh Cosby the only people that are
coming to see you are coming to yell at
you so I would like to witness it
um don't you think like no everyone's
gonna come and just be like Ray bass
like what are we but Cosby here's the
thing about the show because it is in my
opinion one of the best sitcoms Martin
Cosby it's very well made you know we'll
talk it doesn't matter why
um cheers
uh Pilot's perfect but there's some uh
Cosby Show episodes uh like the Cosby
sweater episode and then the the striped
shirt remember the one that he got the
irregular one he wanted the designer one
yeah like there's just
I'm just curious like why I didn't
realize this at the time but like why
was Bill Cosby's character Heathcliff in
why was he a gynecologist
was he a gynecologist yes oh I thought
he was just a doctor I didn't know he
was a guy a gynecologist and by the way
his office was he'd come up the stairs
from his basement and be like all right
done for the day
he took office his office was in his hot
basement
he'd walk up a flight of stare walk
through and then take off plastic gloves
and be like dinner ready that bitch was
gross
[Laughter]
their gloves Heathcliff
they had nothing on him he had by the
way right behind the door he just put
him on and now he's like ah ready to go
what you wouldn't take him off after you
opened a doorknob with them you would
have thrown them in the truck if you had
really used gloves all right kids let's
see if you wanted to use gloves you
would have taken them off downstairs I
never realized that he was a
gynecologist I I have to because then I
would hear like I just delivered a baby
or something you'd be like ah like
obstetrician or something but then at
the time I think my brain was going like
oh it's a good even as a kid I was like
it's a good thing to show black people
as a doctor as doctors and it's safe and
like right what could go wrong you know
this guy's obviously just this wholesome
comedian that like loves jello jigglers
so like perfect but don't you notice
Whitney that all the people that don't
curse and all the people that are like
squeaky fucking clean and they don't
have anything to hide it's you know that
you know they're the ones you're the one
they're the ones and all you
motherfuckers they're like you guys are
low-hanging fruit and you bully and you
punch down well at least behind the
scenes I'm not raping kids we say what
it is right then and there and that's it
and we have nothing to hide we Have No
Secrets uh but you know who does have a
lot of Secrets a man that wears a shirt
that says feminist
oh that's a thousand percent you know
what I'm saying yes why do you need to
wear that like fuck you really I'm a
feminist too first of all who yeah
everyone has to say I'm a feminist I've
hugged my wife recently yeah like well I
don't like what people are like yeah I'm
a fem it's like oh you have to say that
look at this I'm a feminist my car is a
girl
right exactly I mean I don't let anyone
touch her well yeah well I protect her
with my life yeah well mine's white
leather so women aren't allowed in it
but I am a white supremacist white skin
only in the car white skin it had skin
at the end of the day leather is just
skin that's too dark get it out white I
want to be able to fucking see Hitler's
reflection in it did you hear about that
guy that was a c was a serial rapist and
he was the cleanest comic has anyone
raped just once him in like not for me
I'm just I don't know the answer because
I've like ah that wasn't what I was good
as I thought it would be
I'm just curious because it always seems
to be a that is I'm just curious don't
so fucking funny I do that because you
know what that wasn't for me I thought
it would be you know what not what I I
had to go in the bathroom and jerk off
the cops like I couldn't even come with
all the wiggling rape once ago no I'm
you know I thought it would be more
hotter more fun she didn't say no enough
frankly she kind of gave them there was
literally a comic who wouldn't so
squeaky clean yeah Regan Cosby clean and
he would go to college campuses and do
that this was probably I would say can
we name him early early 90s oh yeah and
and something but he so they found out
that he was doing it then by the way you
could get away with fucking ends and I
heard this dude was cleaner than Cosby
and Regan like I heard this guy was like
that's what college students love to to
Comedy they love to watch clean yeah men
talking about like what's up with the
meter maids am I right like yeah and you
know how they got him his schedule
got they got him based on his on his
comedy schedule they were like oh you
were at this college you were at this
college or at this college and they got
him and it's funny but did the girls or
guys uh I don't see gender
um they did the days to report him
they reported the crime and then all of
a sudden they figured it out can I tell
you something about Comics dude
I'm gonna say this because I'm I'm so
proud to be a comic like in general I
haven't always been maybe because of
just bad data and like
uh bad dates I don't know all of it but
um
comics
we will
I mean there are a lot of comics these
days younger ones that I think are um
wildly uh misguided and they think after
seeing Hannibal call out Cosby they
think the way they're gonna get ahead is
to call out their elders and how fucking
dare you it's never gonna work being a
snitch might get me ahead you know you
do the fucking work but so when Hannibal
did that he was already a like he didn't
it actually probably in a way hurt him
because then personally he had to deal
with it because he was touring he was
selling tickets yeah he didn't want to
have to answer this all the time he want
every interview to be about he didn't
want to be defined by Bill Cosby his
whole life he just did a fucking martyr
ass move because no one else would do it
right so like the cool thing about the
real deal Comics is we will fucking
um I hate when people say Throw under
the bus like like you can't throw
someone under the bus who's guilty of a
crime
right you're not I'm a threat you're not
throwing someone under the bus they
committed a crime or many crimes right
and they uh and you brought light to it
yeah yeah so I actually think that
Comics like
uh the real ones
Of Mice and Men 101 will be like this
one I love him he's my brother like he's
gotta go or he can't yeah we can't let
them operate this way or we will fight
for the ones that were wrongly yeah or
unfairly absolutely maligned do you know
what I mean like I think Comics at the
end of the day the real ones are wildly
Fair
and even if yes someone who's been on uh
um unfairly uh taken to their knees
uh for too long how about that even the
people that would benefit from that
person going away forever because they'd
get more specials or air time or
bookings which isn't true there's enough
I think forever yeah yeah exactly we
fight to get him back yeah and you know
what I don't like because we need them
to fight for us when we fucking get this
was your Halloween costume from 10 years
ago we'll all go we'll protect our pack
yeah and I think the comedy community
does that when somebody's down but I
agree like I don't like I I've been
doing this almost 20 I've been to this
20 years okay
17. I think that the I think
that this new generation is talking too
much about each other of comics yeah
like you don't sit down and talk hey
what do you think about so-and-so's conf
going and I'm like first of all that
person may have a family that's going to
watch this I don't know like I'm not
gonna talk shit about this how about
this
why are you speaking to me about my own
friends at all yeah why are we doing
this on a comedy podcast
why do you have a podcast who are you
right you have you have nothing to say
except talking about other Comics that
do have something to say exactly so why
don't you stop your this stop
um
embarrassing yourself and all of us
frankly and putting us on jury duty
David Spade calls podcast jury duty
um yeah and stop making me drive to your
garage
to talk shit about my friends yeah yeah
it's like it's because that's for your
seven fans oh so you can get in the
algorithm of saying somebody this is
what I don't like I don't like is that
can people hear that
okay sorry
um I don't like when new comedians
younger generations of comedians aren't
comedy fans
right so when I was coming up like still
am whatever who cares uh uh I loved
comedian I loved watching comedy yeah I
would like run in the fucking room if
Bill Burr was on I would run in the room
with Lucy K and pop by run in the room
if Patrice was on like I was like
instead of just being like
I'm fucking taking him down you just
watch it's like what the fuck are you
doing yeah how about all these older
Comics or more experienced Legends quite
frankly that's right that you should be
so fucking lucky to be alive at the same
time with get their fucking names out of
your mouth and maybe go watch them work
and learn something a hundred percent
like you loved the comedy you loved the
comedy you love being in the comedy you
love the room these people are like what
the fuck do they do what can I do what
yeah those people just Of Mice and Men
you bring them in the woods and just
yeah just let them back just let Lenny
pet the rabbit yes or but we also have
to just like stay away from these people
because they're dangerous yeah like
they're just dangerous yeah you know
like that's what comedy is you know so
we're all just like coping and we're all
trying to heal for better for worse yes
we're not trying to piss you off we're
not trying to get some trans people
can't use a Exxon Mobile bathroom by the
way no one should be using a gas station
bathroom babies toddlers emergency only
no by the way just outside just outside
behind the gas station in the grass dude
I was taking a shit listen to this I was
taking a shit in a Target
right by the way Target or is it targets
and McDonald's are great places to take
dude I had to take shit I think it was
either Target or stoppage it was either
no it doesn't stop it no it was stop it
shop stop it shops no Stop and Shop is a
grocery store copy it's like what what's
your big grocery store out here what's
the big uh well Whole Foods is a money
laundering scheme
is like the Neiman Marcus of groceries
okay so stop and shop is like a Ralph's
whatever and I something happened I'm
shopping with the cart I had to go so
bad and I just and I actually go do this
I put my cart with all the shit in it
and I run to the bathroom and I go down
and a dude is waiting and he's going oh
hurry up and I swear to God he put his
eye in the crack
Whitney he went like this he went like
this
dude what the f I go yo he put his eye
it was like a goblin it was like a
goblin that happened that gargoyle yeah
yeah big gargoyle energy I don't know if
I've ever been more vulnerable in my
life I'm sitting down on the toilet and
a grown man is going
he's gonna hurry
it was the fucking most horrifying thing
so this place is ever let's rename it
stop and shit because that is what it is
number one number two you guys and your
shit so a couple things
when guys go take shits and how do we
get here
we're Comics I mean we're the best what
were we saying right before don't try to
get out of the shit conversation no I'll
talk shit all day sorry Stacy
um uh so I'll talk soon all day that's
all we do is talk shit but we never talk
about actual poopy so I don't like
talking about poop is my lead I don't I
don't like farts or poop jokes or any of
that but I do want you all to know men
you are physically unwell
uh your shits you should be shitting
like three times a day smaller shits
that come out you should you shouldn't
have to sit on the shitter for like
any more than truly like
four minutes like and that's leaving
with like checking a couple times shits
three times a day you should be that's
how it's supposed to be isn't it one in
the morning a nice healthy one in the
morning and you're done to eat
vegetables and fiber like once a month
like
once or twice a month maybe let's just
start there because when I hear guys
talk I hear this story a lot not this
exact one but like somebody was looking
with their eyes no no no that's that's
just you that's just your ordeal that's
something you manifested remember when
you didn't prepare to fail so you failed
you should have prepared to the bathroom
first maybe we need to have a backup
plan for that what did you call him a
gargoyle it's a fucking guard they're
always dude if you're shitting and
stopping shit what are the chances that
seven other dudes are right behind you
zero oh that's what you said this I know
how we got there you said who's you
can't shit in a in a gas station oh no
no you can you shouldn't so when a
parent is like my child was in a gas
station with a drag queen
I was like why was your child why was
your child in the fucking gas station
bathroom yeah all day what the fuck were
you doing plan to get your time
management together well here's the
thing with kids it's tough
because you know what how about this
okay my dad a fucking Legend okay Legend
we left the house and he go do you have
to pee I'm like no and be like
we're not stopping oh okay he would
let's let you know and then we'd like I
need to stop he'd be like I said we're
not stopping no I said did you think and
then it was a whole thing my dad was
like a like a kind of criminal defense
attorney in a way but like he would not
cave to biological limitations and he
would train you to pee before because
then parents will I'm not stopping and
then 20 minutes I have to pee all right
let's stop now you now your child just
doesn't respect you at all you work for
them now my dad was like I'm the dad and
you're the kid yeah and I don't
accommodate you
peeing every five minutes we would he
I'd hold it for four out DC to Virginia
Roanoke Virginia like there was no I
want something to drink well then you're
gonna have to pee like there was no
stopping every you know it's cool
everything you said about your dad it
seems like he was it's all it was all
preparation for you like when you were
like the hugging wasn't hugging but it
was like that's a scam be careful of
that because that they're gonna fuck you
in life he was preparing you for for
everything and it seems like tough love
but it's also giving an education on
life which is dope and I'm so dumb not
dumb I'm just so I grew up in a culture
of everything as our parents fault and
we only look at the negative and I think
that something I really hope podcasts
are doing is talking to the younger
generation going it's always you your
parents like stop blaming them certainly
through Recon yeah but there's
absolutely no version and if this isn't
the case either call the police or
cut them out of your life entirely
there's I don't believe there's any
parent that wakes up and it's like I'm
gonna fuck up my kid today all right
right no no it's like when you see
someone who's not well dressed or not
fashionably dressed like they like
fucking
thought they nailed it
no one is like I'm gonna look like an
idiot going to Vegas with my Hugo Boss
shirt Hugo Boss Nazi designer whatever
different conversation for a different
day so like I just think there's this
new trend where we blame our parents for
everything they do the best they can and
if it falls short yeah you're 47.
your dad didn't throw the ball with you
all right
go heal yourself well no what you should
do is your dad didn't have time throw
the ball with your son or make up that's
what I do like things that I didn't
things that I felt like I would have
loved by the way maybe you were shitty
at ball throwing he tried and was like
this is a waste of my time yeah maybe
you were I mean I wasn't as I'm saying
but the people because there's this new
thing I don't know if it's just La guys
but like we're older men like either
that I've that I'll just keep it
personal that I've dated that are like
worried I'm gonna like me to them or
something as if I fucking have the time
to give a shit
it's so funny when people go are you
gonna you're gonna me too me yeah I want
you to be my number one Google search
you fucking loser yeah I'm gonna spend
who says are you gonna you like me you
do me like even worse
or YouTube you I don't know you dude I
don't care about you the new me too is
the YouTube
that's the new me too you too
not me no one's even tried to me how
that's fucking how my favorite is all of
the comics that haven't been famous
enough to be me too and they're like
annoyed about it I mean that's like when
they're like well it's coming for me
it's coming it's like it's never coming
do you want to know what what's sick
about this business oh there's a lot but
especially you know and I don't want to
just I don't wanna in the comedy
business I think Hollywood and comedy a
different some are like absolutely I
bifurcated at this point there are
people that just want to be rich and
famous and all and all I can do is speak
for me and my personally I want to be
rich and famous because of this I want
rich and I want money and and fame to
come as a byproduct of that I want to
get great at that and then have people
go yo that's Paul verzie I want him for
this show I want him to act in that I
want to be known for that I know by the
way they might ask you to act in it and
you might say no because it's not enough
money and you're gonna be away from your
kids for too long right and these are
the real fucking deals motherfucker
Mafia Comics the ones that I don't want
anything I don't deserve no I never want
most people dip a lot of sorry a lot of
younger generation Comics want stuff
they don't deserve and they're not ready
I Whitney my first album night at the
stand I was 14 years in before I put
anything out 14 years then myself I was
on last call of Carson Daley six months
in and everyone loved it not good for
you that was way too soon that's what I
say with yeah but you know what if you
nailed it and it was I didn't real it
got me a job as a writer on the show and
I needed health insurance and I needed I
had no money but I think that like when
people say to me like isn't it hard to
be a female Community it's hard to be a
comedian for everyone all the time for
different reasons but I think I got a
lot of opportunities before I was ready
because they just needed a girl well you
know what though but you did the work to
get there and like some people just take
that but I talked to this one comic he's
like yeah I'm on my third album I'm like
how long you've been doing it it's like
six years I'm like nobody's lit by the
way just make one decent one and like
yeah but that's fine but yeah that's
that's fine like no one's going to
listen to it anyway so who cares it's
like that's just practice you're you
know right fine or if you're making
money we want to be rich and famous
because we know what rich and famous
means and it means freedom it means
freedom to play the venues we want to
cancel if we have to because the kid is
sick and the fans will understand uh to
tour when we want how we want where we
want to be able to take time to uh like
that's what it affords you is freedom
and flexibility and that's something you
don't have when you don't have Rich and
being rich and famous and for everyone
that wants to be famous uh I don't think
there's anything wrong with that like I
think we all want that I think everyone
wants that and not even famous or but
recognition for the good things they've
done so you know a truck driver in
Pensacola
Pensacola is truly I do 80 cities a year
70. it's the only city for some reason
when I think of a city that comes up I
only say pencil like I don't say Toledo
I don't say I don't throw Salt Lake in
there ever truly never but unless I'm
talking about plastic surgery because it
has the highest plastic surgery rate in
the country no yes it does yes Salt Lake
City think about it wow you're a Mormon
Woman by 23 you've had seven kids and
then your husband decides to move on to
a different Mormon family and you gotta
fucking uh uh read circumcise your
entire body yeah you have to get a new
face that wasn't the one that was raped
by Brigham Young so that someone else
will entertain the idea of speaking with
you because you're out to pasture at 23.
can I just remind everyone sorry uh time
out for Whitney to um try to cancel a
cult do you know that the Mormon song
that the girls sing every Friday night
for the men when starting at four years
old to 12 is keep sweet keep sweet
what the whole deal is so that kid can
you pull up
we're getting the same every time you
say that for somebody we get the same
reaction they go what that's why I keep
talking about it until I talk about it
and someone goes I've heard that they
should they we should
um put gasoline on the homes of the
Mormon men uh remove the children uh
bring them to Whitney's house I don't
know I'll find something for them to do
and then set them on fire it's hard to
do in the snow and they know that which
is why they're there
I'm gonna fucking wait until the snow's
melted
and I'm fucking coming for you all the
more Mormons just gotta go
the ones that have the child Brides
there's a crazy documentary under the
banner of heaven but I think they did a
documentary on it okay so they're still
marrying 12 year olds and um what just
know
coming for you
you know what you know one of my wife's
biggest problems with me is hold on can
I guess
love this game
is it Keynesian economics are you
spending to make money back or do you
feel like it's a little bit of a
gambling addiction no no no no no no no
I'm I'm like we're going first class
with beds and hot meals the whole way
okay okay but you're not a big spender
because if you didn't you two would be
divorced by now I need to and my wife is
like do we really need yes because we
tour and we're on planes all the time
when I'm not with you baby girl I'll fly
middle seat uh fucking uh Spirit
Airlines but if it's me but I won't you
won't because you've graduated but you
have I have so when someone's like oh
you only fly first class I'm like hey
bitch I have four I I have 15 years
under my belt of middle seat Southwest
toilet flush a flu VM of toilet toilet
getting hit by the toilet door yeah
nothing openings for Craig Shoemaker so
I need you yes I'm Gonna Fly First Class
by the way on points you fucking dork
sorry anyway no I'm just I would like to
say you're investing in your marriage
I'm not SP what I say if someone's like
you're spending a lot on that I'm like
no I'm just investing in US yeah because
if we fly back there I know why can't we
just do the exit row with that extra
because the someone next to us is going
to have a Ziploc bag full of hard-boiled
eggs
and they're gonna open it and then I'm
going to uh behave in a way that will
send me to jail for a couple years yeah
and you'll be a single mother yeah yeah
so those are your choices
[Laughter]
when I think about this kind of stuff
and for some reason since my mom died
it's like I just like came flooding to
me that I was like oh it's your job to
like kill pedophiles
like it's like my brain is just like has
been able to catch up because it's like
I haven't Epstein and all this it's like
it's a lot to process as a human being
and I think that if you're a parent you
probably just can't even you can protect
your kid I mean I was looking for
backpacks for my nieces you know they
live in England I think that's I you
know I don't really know what goes on
over there but I looked up backpacks
online and the first things that came up
were bulletproof backpacks
and I literally had to go for a walk and
just like cry because I was like every
time you see a school shooting you're
kind of like okay another one another
one like we we desensitize ourselves we
have to it's it's coping magnet and then
you see that and you're like like oh
dude in my mouth you want to hear
something sad I'll go ahead I don't know
if you were no I just think that I'm I'm
like 40. I just went off uh birth
control I've been on it for 25 years and
that puts your brain like in a state of
uh kind of I can only
um of hyper vigilance in a way that is
for your own um stead like nesting area
but you're not able to kind of think
about other problems because you have a
forthcoming child and you have to kind
of focus on that you know but when
because birth control tells your body
it's pregnant that's how it works right
right so the only way to not get
pregnant is already be pregnant right so
you're basically four months pregnant or
fight all the time on birth control so
you're thinking as if a pregnant woman
would you have Mom brain you're kind of
is that right yeah so I just went off of
I talked about this in um the the my
third special kind of button and you
also smell men different differently or
olfactory glands you would look for a
different kind of person if your partner
if you're pregnant versus if you're not
right wow so you want a risk taker when
you're not pregnant because you want
someone that's you know and then you
want someone who's going to help you
protect the baby when you're pregnant so
they always say that if you're on birth
control and you're and got engaged to
the love of your life first go off birth
control for like a year and see if you
still
it's still your guy so a lot of times
people break get divorced and break up
because they got together when she's on
birth control and then like two years
later she goes off it and she's they're
like dumping along anymore wow you know
wow it's wild that is wild wild that
like changes a whole relationship based
on that wow so now I'm off birth control
and I'm just like
sea org Scientology Mormons I'm fucking
coming for you because I'm like can
focus on other things besides my own
hormonal fucking you want to know why
because Life's a box of pedophiles by
the way it's a it's actually a boat of
pedophiles
life's like a floating box
that's so my brain is just I think that
comics and I'm like so obsessed with you
and your work and I was watching I had
seen nocturnal emissions because every
guy that I have ever dated uh is so
obsessed with you that I get to watch
that's a great thing I appreciate it I
get to watch like my friends or future
friends like I feel like we're becoming
friends and you go on a rant I TR I did
a version of it uh a version of the rant
about this but it was from like kind of
what I saw about the royal family oh
yeah breaking open our obsession with
the royal family and the way you said it
it was like our obsession with this
magical family this Disney fan or
whatever the fuck it was it just like
shattered it in such a like I just think
thank you it's just Comics It's Like
Comics takes are worth waiting for so
it's like you're online looking at like
these really pithy uh facile takes on
the Royal Family late just wait for the
fucking comic the Silverbacks to come in
after we've molded around a bit just
give us a second it's like when when
everyone's trying to go like what do we
do with the information about like
um Talking Enron or whatever and
everyone's like but here's my take and
then there's like six months in Bill
Burr is just like and like that's the
take and it's over yeah you know what I
mean that's what I think great Comics do
oh I appreciate yeah it's funny you said
that because I remember Brian Regan
talked about who I think Brian's
incredible Brian talked about airplanes
and I was gonna do a joke about getting
on an airplane and I said a comic had to
touch this and Brian Regan has a seven
minute clip and dude when I tell you he
hits is there a reason it's over you
can't no comedian can talk about waiting
at the gate there's nothing else getting
in the plane the back of the plane the
front of the plane what you eat the
whole experience of getting to the
airport and getting off a plane you
can't do it anymore so here's the deal
with real Comics that don't steal from
other Comics or don't want to you know
com so when the comic accidentally
steals like I didn't know you're doing
that
okay so no one in the comedy community
gave you a heads up or was like oh hey
just you know so like we all know you
know what I mean someone either you're
either an asshole and no one gave you a
heads up and we're like let's see how
this goes you know or like Fortune
themester her last special am I like we
were or you're not in the clubs working
stuff out yeah other people would see
and go oh hey so-and-so's doing version
that but it's not close like it's not
the same right you're doing a bit on
right uh Spirit Airlines he's doing
something on Southwest just just like
heads up and it's different right we
give each other heads up yes just so
it's not uh hey just so you know he's
touching that or she's touching that but
it's not the you're going in a different
direction totally and then I would and I
go oh my God that's what real Comics too
whoever uh uh Judy tenuta is also doing
something on um whatever birth control
pills she's dead rest in peace but like
you would tell me that if you saw me and
then I would call her and go oh hey
what's yours what's my ah you know what
yours is better I'll stop you know
whatever or yeah so Fortune feamster uh
calls me after I'm at The Comedy Store
one night and she's like I'm doing a
thing on Red Rover you know Red Rover
Red Rover his kids and I was like oh
shit what's yours and she and she goes
it's totally different than yours I
think we can both do it I'm like I think
we can both do them too yeah they're so
different like that's how real Comics
yeah yes talk to each other yeah because
I think a lot of comics they see that
someone else is doing something kind of
similar instead of talking they're like
let me just shoot mine first yeah and
then that person works on it for six
months and then people go oh well you
stole from or that person just did
something on yeah seesaws what and
you're like well they could have told me
because they knew you know what I'm
saying yeah what's weird is like I felt
like there was a comic I'm obviously not
gonna mention names but I felt like
there was a comic who saw me working on
Sinbad and then they did it and they did
something similar on late night and
because they wanted they want to shit on
the premise especially if it's
undercooked so if a great comic like you
is doing a fucking incredible bit on the
Godfather right and then they just want
to shit on the premise I've had a couple
Comics do this to me where
um uh they know I'm doing something on a
certain thing and then they'll just do
like little quick yeah to where it just
looks like they got to it first but mine
is 30 minutes of like I've been thinking
about this for two years possible and
then they just do it like as a reference
yes like a quick little throwaway and
you worked out this long and they know
you're doing it but they just want to
fucking make yours they just want to
with a little fucking flick flick of the
ear or like some shitty thing you do in
high school just make your two-year
original work feel less original I
remember when I was and I'm gonna go
back to the sad story and not it's not a
sad story it's actually a good story but
I want to tell you the uh
what we're talking about now so my
special my first special I'll say this
on Comedy Central came out in 2018 right
I was doing a joke about going to a
rescue shelter and getting dogs yeah
right and I was going I said each cage
has a story right so I was going down
the whole list and I was like oh she's a
Rottweiler she's amazing she's beautiful
here's the thing and it would just and
then it would get exaggerated and
somebody hit me up somebody hit me up
and somebody just goes dude man I'm so
sorry and I go what they're like Louie's
special came out and Louie did the thing
and Louie did it mine was a three minute
thing now Louie's brilliant he's
incredible but I had a three minute
thing of when I show up to the rescue
thing and I go down every cage and it
was so and when I tell you it left it
was hitting and Louie just goes yeah
yeah that dog yeah she didn't like
pennies right she doesn't like pennies
and I was like he so I did that down the
whole list and got exaggerated he did it
quick but it's over now it's over now
now I can't it's over it's over his
special came out you know what you can
do I believe nothing should ever be
wasted sorry to interrupt or be it this
guy I don't know why you can't have
Louie on your podcast and then just talk
about it yeah do your version yeah and
he's gonna go that's so funny yeah and
then you have a clip yeah yeah and then
you'll put it on his website yeah on if
he wants whatever because he's putting
like well that's the beauty of this now
or yeah yeah like you do it and then we
have it for socials we put it on my
socials your socials and then it's out
there but it wasn't but God forbid it
wasn't on Comedy Central which no one
can even watch anymore because you'd
have to download an Adobe Acrobat Reader
file to even know where you have to do a
fucking you have to do a treasure hunt
by the way you just have to go to the
offices like if you want to watch this
comedy Center special you have to just
drive down to their main Viacom offices
and um at gunpoint tell people like how
the fuck I want to watch
I'm so afraid of mispronouncing your
name that I just panicked I would have
to put a gun to the executive's head and
say no no you'd have to put a gun to
like nine people's head to get you to
the executive Because by the way the
executive is um uh I mean look not and
let's be honest not working that's not
they don't go to work they're
celebrating a holiday that um they're
celebrating Columbus Day they're off
um you know what I mean so you would
have to put a gun to so many interns
unpaid interns heads yeah to then be
like I want to see
but by the way Tommy Central sponsor it
was never an hour they were like 42
minutes yeah they were like yeah I got
it got cut down but um
no you did something really cool that I
really appreciate and that's why I was
like oh man like I like to to do her
shows when
um I was tour after the after this came
out I did all the I did all the the pots
yeah and I stopped in Austin I did Rogan
I did everything and like you and a
couple people were people that I didn't
do so I hit you up and I was like hey
man do you do you think um hey man I
don't I was are they just so you know
people are like isn't it scary to be in
comedy around all these guys they call
me man and dude I'm fine yeah they don't
see me as a female I appreciate it I
like it no I call anybody I say every
dude a man to everybody but what I will
say yeah real quick
the most uh the most romantic moment of
my life how about that okay I was I was
in uh uh Burbank
okay Starbucks is here there's a Jamba
Juice and a Panda Express there's three
guys in theirs and it's a parking lot
giant like mini mall
I walk by it you know when you as a girl
you or a guy really you there's a group
of three and it's you we will always I
believe go to our primordial brain of
like
just making sure just
there's three on one and we're and I and
do I make eye contact to let them know
I'm not the person to fuck with even
though we're in front of a Jamba Juice
in Burbank yeah and it's fine
you still go into your fight or flight
like yeah this just assessing for pro
possible problem you know what I mean or
as girls sometimes you just like walk by
and completely ignore them to know like
we're not but I know you're gonna like
look at me so I'm gonna kind of fucking
let you know what you're never gonna get
or whatever yeah and I'm not gonna do
that thing where I try to make someone
want to fuck me that I'm not don't even
want to talk to and also I have to be
I'm late for work also so this is a wild
embryo
yeah to be in so there's these these
guys whatever pagers probably uh it's
like two years ago and um I walk by and
I'm like these fucking losers whatever
fucking whatever I'm thinking fucking
Supreme dorks yeah yeah you know if I
can Puma full sweatsuit guy never gonna
happen not one gold chain like three
maybe like an e like a pony like a baby
like a man bun who the fucking v-neck
whatever and I walk by and there's this
the guy in the middle is like the ring
leader whoever just looks at me and goes
uh
what's up dude
and I literally I'm like Ugh gross and
then I go into Starbucks and I'm like
wait do like does he think dude that's
why not but hold on does he think like
was why would you call me dude if I'm uh
why wouldn't you say what's up Ma or why
wouldn't you say like like you're
wearing those pants or like whatever did
he not think I was hot wait a minute
you're wearing those pants as a ghost
that's a big one yeah you're wearing
those jeans oh okay yeah that's like you
look good in those jeans but dude is
kind of like him saying that was kind of
didn't make you feel like you it makes
you feel less I think about him every
day
that's what I'm saying that's a cool I
it's I take it use it it is the hottest
thing that's ever happened to me my wife
though said to me she goes can you not
call me dude because I called Mom that's
your wife so obviously don't do that
yeah yeah because that's um uh spousal
abuse
if you must buy lingerie for your lady
first of all don't yeah uh second of all
don't try to guess her size
lingerie's dumb
it's not okay all right so
you say it's done okay then what okay so
Billy say before your wife because
you've never watched porn then why do
you guys watch it so much watch what you
launch women in lingerie why if it's so
dumb I don't but there are some
platforms where we can't just be Buck
Naked we have to we have to lingerie's
dumb we do have to cover up our vaginas
and tits somehow
because we have oh you're talking about
underwear well yeah we have a gaping
hole like just which I like interest in
our imagines having a gaping hole
somewhere on your body besides your
butthole which is not gaping it's really
hidden
like we have an open wound
for like our whole life yeah I I didn't
know it was going to go it's more of a
bandage than everyone else I I yeah I
think I immediately regret it says if
it's more of a uh like a one of many
like uh uh sort of meaningless rape
deterrence uh I shouldn't say it's
listen I'm just trying to get some
layers between me and the bus stop I'm
sitting on that I get but that's
underwear right lingerie great but I
don't only want to wear lingerie that
makes me um feel like uh I'm uh Shirley
Temple for example like I kind of I it's
from why is can I have cute lingerie
like I if I it's for me right if it's
for you yeah yeah okay I know you think
we buy luxury for you
kinda like isn't that part of it though
like isn't that part of the whole
no
so you would get it regardless if there
was like a date night or like something
babies for you the Period Panties are
for you
well yeah no you know what I've been
married now 15 years I'm trying to think
of like when the kids are gone we'll do
that but when the kids are there it's
tough it's tough to be intimate when
kids are I talk about it in my special
but you can do it without the laundry I
think yeah yeah once you get to that do
you have to schedule I I was talking to
someone about this and she's like we
have to schedule it which isn't
necessarily very it's kind of sexy even
if we never get to it it's like fun to
schedule it
there'll be a time where like I'll get
frisky and she'll go and she'll be into
it and she'll go but we got you know we
gotta wait we gotta wait because they're
in the house yeah like they're either
yeah they're either in the house or get
they're getting picked up or they're
doing something well she's gonna have an
orgasm you gotta wait but if not
you know what I mean there's two kinds
of sex for women there's the kind that's
just like you're gonna come in two
seconds in the bathroom and don't do it
inside me so it's not dripping down my
leg the whole rest of the fucking day
while I'm at work or the kind where she
actually has an orgasm and you got to
block out like four and a half hours
yeah that and cover the bed with cash
you know I mean
and like yeah no that that obviously has
got to be babysitter kids out kids at
the end that's a whole other thing
that's a date night yeah but I feel like
there's some I feel like a lot of like
guys that are like really into women
having orgasms like that's really hot
but like it's not gonna happen in the
two when a guy is just like let's just
get frisky real quick let's have a real
no no that's a quickie and then you they
fucking like how come you didn't come
and you're like what I've I'm standing
up yeah I'm on a call yeah I muted a
call so you can fuck me yeah yeah and
come and I now I just need you to leave
me alone and finish that's more yeah but
you know what big thing I have other
things to finish a big thing to do in
marriage it's a very big thing to do
what saves a matter what can really help
a matter tell me is is definitely Dayton
you have to do date night you have to do
date night you have to go back to dating
even if you're married 10 15 years with
children you have to have date night can
I uh is that the quarterback taken out
his offensive line can I a bad a little
bit oh interesting but I think for men
listening because you know I basically
honestly I feel like I think more like a
man than most men he's going well I
already fucking put in eight grand to
date her
before we got married it just I think a
lot of guys think date night expenses
they're dummies they're dumb right but I
think that there's a way to do date
night that doesn't have to be like we go
to this Italian restaurant and spend 300
bucks because like no it's not even
about that what it's about is it's
connecting back to when you were dating
can date night be like we may we get a
sitter or the kids do sleepover and we
stay home and make dinner together no no
okay date night needs to be I want to
sit across from you at the table glasses
of wine and we're gonna talk like we
used to talk when we were dating and and
and to re- kind of get what it was like
when we were getting to the level we're
at so for the guys that do want to do so
do you have to act uh the way you acted
in the beginning like trying to uh
impress this is the problem with date
night with couples right for me when you
first start dating someone you're like
putting your best foot forward and
you're like oh my God I would love to
see The Godfather like oh my God
Scarface oh my God I can't wait to watch
it like you know it hasn't seen good
films oh my God and then you're like
where you know and you're like really
like and then you're like I know and
then I rescued this kid and he almost
like we're putting our best foot forward
so then I feel like date night 15 years
later yeah it's just like I'm not
fucking watching Scarface again dude I'm
not it's not like we might have to go
also emotionally when we go to date
night back to the people we were when we
were trying to get that person to love
us yeah I think
neither me or Stacy have really changed
a lot since we like that's probably why
you're we were kind of like that we're
so we're so opposite like you were
instantly 15 years married yeah we're so
opposite and it makes it work I think
opposite when I used to hear that and go
different I think that means sometimes
compatible yes because when people go
like we're just opposites I'm like no no
that's why you're yeah an incredible
team yes she's she's very much like
regimented organized she's super super
smart super super you know I'm lit I'm
laid back
um but she's with lions um Lions male
lions sleep 22 hours a day and the women
do all the hunting I'm a very laid-back
kind of easy going and it takes a lot to
really upset me because I've been
through a lot of shit in my life where I
realize things don't matter yeah and uh
not not that other people's issues are
nothing you know totally but I think
that a uh the smartest people or
whatever smart forget your attachment
that word the ones that live the
happiest life lives yeah know what uh
Hills to die on yes and what that so now
not a battle worth fighting dude I say
both of those things in my new hour nice
both of those things you just said in
manure you gotta pick and choose the
hill you're gonna fucking die on and you
get one a year and there's not there's a
lot of things you've got to let go and
if it doesn't involve children's safety
it's probably not worth it the dumb the
Dumber version of me as a husband fought
everything because that's because he
drives that's all eager like you ain't
gonna get the last you ain't getting the
last well fuck that that's wrong you
know you're and I got now I go and
that's the wrong kind of Guido and this
is the right kind of Guido yeah and yeah
because I would be like what the fuck
like you know I would say stupid shit
I'd be like who do you think you're
talking to like who are you talking to
right like I would do that shit and it
becomes about not about what you're
saying it becomes about how you're
saying it yes and I'm like okay yeah I'm
happy to pick uh do what you need me to
do but you don't need to fucking talk to
me like that in front of people it
becomes about right and then fight
you don't know me
that's you know I said to my wife once I
said to my wife I go if you think I'm
gonna be this is what I said this I
actually said this to my vehicle if you
think I'm gonna be one of these fucking
pussies you drag or talk you know do
that drag around you're with the wrong
motherfucker like and do stay in that
stuff and you put the wrong motherfucker
but I'm not leaving I'm staying because
I kind of might like it on some level
you don't even know I'm gonna fucking
tell you bitch yeah I'm out of here if
you do that again
but my life actually appreciate my wife
the one thing my wife appreciates is
when I am you know she was like my wife
doesn't like a pushover here's what I'm
saying that women like I'm not sure no
no and if they do
you know push them over like yeah um uh
a lot of times I think in relationships
we want love we think we want love and
we do but I think at the end of the day
it all boils under we actually want
respect and we and Love sometimes is
like that's that's big that's true and
that's what I took me a long time to
realize that and then we want the other
person to respect us more than we
respect ourselves yeah so when we
exhibit self-respect in a way that
doesn't undermine us of like you better
fucking respect me dude no no that will
never work yeah right if you just go you
know you know what
I need to process this conversation I'm
going to just take a walk around the
block if that's okay yeah because I'm
about to say something that I can't take
back see I don't I'm not I I needed to
evolve to that I'm not there yet either
because I got that fucking Sicilian time
like you know what a fucker you know
it's like yeah I know you are Paul I
know tonight I said you're making it so
I don't want to fuck you
okay
make me figure it out yeah yeah you know
I mean I my thing is being I won't let
something just corrode without telling
the other person I'll go like hey here's
what's happening yeah this thing is I
I'll fix what I need to fix on my part
yeah but like I can't initiate sex I
don't like it yeah right but you're
always busy yeah
push me in the closet yeah and fuck me
when you've seen in my calendar I have
10 minutes by the way I'm asking you to
commit a crime
yeah how funny would it be if my wife
when I go you know who the fuck I am
she's like yeah you tell dick jokes and
strip malls that's who you are that's
who I married which is by the way way
braver than a lot of fucking other a lot
of other games by the way strip malls I
think you mean strip clubs okay
you just gave to see you do respect me
you just gave me a fucking promotion
yeah yeah right
um okay so talk to me real quick about
your tour podcasts uh you're still doing
the one with the bill no no I haven't I
haven't but it's still up though what's
that it's still up the podcast that you
and Bill used to do okay now me oh the
podcast with Bill yes so we do yeah yeah
I'm sorry I thought you said two yes so
I do two podcasts uh the version effect
which is now a TV show in studio in New
York City which is fantastic
um don't worry he doesn't live in New
York City you'll be able to relate to
him yes uh me and Bill Burr co-host one
together called anything better
um the special nocturnal admissions man
it was trending globally I'm so thankful
for everybody that watched it and how
good it's doing it really there was this
thing where they went
men straight men don't get to do comedy
anymore and everyone's like what how
about just really funny ones that didn't
rape anyone so everyone's so excited to
just be like the balance might be
restored yes everyone you know I mean
it's not about checking boxes of it's
just the best comics and that that's why
that was really nice that it was just
like this comedy should be out here and
and that's what I love and yeah I'm
going on going on a big tour uh starting
uh the Royal Theater in Toronto the 28th
of this month January 28th of this month
Gotham Comedy Club I'm coming back to
New York City's Gotham
I'm just curious because there's like if
I'm gonna go do clubs in New York I'm
always like I feel such an allegiance to
Carolines but they close Caroline's
closed but it was either Gotham or
Carolines and I was cool with that Foot
Locker follow suit yeah uh but no
February second and third I'm at Gotham
is the first time in New York since I
did my special
Valentine's Day I'll be bringing your
date to the Pittsburgh improv I'm doing
a Tuesday night Tuesday I know there's
an Andy Warhol Museum in Pittsburgh is
there oh nice and then all the dates are
at paulversity.com but I'm going
everywhere nice I'm going down for a
Salt Lake Because by the way this is the
best time in the world to see his
special just came out so you're gonna
watch this and you're gonna fucking love
that guy and you're gonna go see him and
he's gonna have a whole new hour yes I
have a whole new hour so you get this
for free yes I mean Netflix I don't know
what the fuck they charge it's I mean
they take your data I don't who cares at
this point but you'll see a new hour for
sure new hour dude that is like but I
love the math of comics like putting it
he was working on the new one while he
was editing this like I just love it
that's right because that's something we
could do to be The Magicians like last
night I saw you do and then I'm seeing
you tonight it's a whole new one yeah oh
oh I gotta tell you this can I tell you
this before we go all right so this is a
story You're Gonna Love
um my wife who knows me very well and I
like sometimes when she says some my
wife no here's the thing about my wife
my wife knows certain things to say that
make me can't let go like if if she
wants to dig if she'll know if I say
that to him he can't so I I what you let
me ask me like as if if she wants to say
something to get a thorn in your side
she knows what to say to rile you up she
knows that if she says that and gets
that thorn and she does it rare like
Scarface
like a dinner party my father's kind of
overrated like she knows yeah like I
don't like your new car like yeah no but
she she knows how to hurt you like no
one else can she'll know that if she
says it I have to come with something
back but you know what the most gangster
move is is to be like no no so this is I
have nothing to I agree this is the
story I take uh which I don't do I'm not
big on I'm not big on I'm not big on
drugs in general I I I drink I'll drink
like booze uh here and there and but
like I got a sponsor gave us like edible
right but it was like a low edible so I
take the slow edible and I'm chilling
and I'm not usually good with it but
this one was such a low dose that I was
actually good so I go to bed this is how
much my wife knows me this is crazy I
don't do and I don't know right so I go
I go to the bedroom and we got I think I
came in late or she said something so
she made a comment then I just made a
comment I go this and then she said
something that would normally get me and
I was in such a good mood and easy that
I just didn't say anything and I laid
down relaxed and she sits up she waits
this is how much this woman knows me a
couple minutes ago she just sits up she
goes wait a minute wait a minute
I hit the fucking tennis ball over and
I'm just she goes wait a minute did you
I swear to God and she knows I don't do
this she goes did you
did you take an edible and I go no and I
just go to bed and the next day why did
you think a lot do you think the edible
made you lie all right the edible and I
just and I just the next morning we wake
up and she goes wow she goes I I thought
you were really coming with something
when I said that and I go uh she goes
you take something I go yeah you took an
antibike I took an edible she goes I
fucking knew it she knew but I never
take it um I'm not gonna let you uh be
late because I respect you too much
um uh so all of your tour dates are
gonna be on paulversey.com nice yeah
Percy guys it's it's ver Z it's
v-i-r-z-i uh it's Paul verzi and uh yeah
paulversy.com
thank you for having me dude thank you
so much for coming like thank you for
putting up with my madness no thank you
for having me and thank you for you know
keeping your word to me and all that and
anytime you come to New York hit me up
anyone that doesn't keep their word you
don't get thank you for that that's the
least you can do yeah well thanks this
is this is a lot of fun dude I love you
uh Paul
let's go versus
okay good versie yes Paul furzie Paul
because sometimes I get scared and then
I'll fuck it up I love you enjoyless
feelings thank you so much everybody
let's go we should be so lucky no ride
elephants bye
[Music]
all right